ادماننا على الهواتف الذكيه واجهزه
الحاسوب وكل انواع التكنولوجيا وعدم
مفارقتها ولو لحظات باتوقعنا
العديد من الخبراء الى دراسه مدى تاثير
تعلقنا بالتكنولوجيا حتى على اشكالنا
الخارجيه الباحثون ابتكروا نموذجا وهذا
النموذج يقدم لمحه عما يمكن ان يبدو عليه
البشر في اقل من 800 عام انسان عام 3000
وما بعده صوره العلماء بظهر المنحنى وعنق
عريض
ومن هي خليفه مع زميله المستقبل التي تم
تصوير نموذج لها في عام 2019 لتصليت الضوء
على اهميه ظروف مكان العمل
سنوات من النظر الى هواتفنا الذكيه او الى
شاشات الكمبيوتر ستغير اشكالنا على النحو
الغريب وفقا لنموذج مندي ساعات النظر
الطويله الى هواتف ناس ستؤدي الى ظهور
انحناءات في الظهر وليس ذلك فحسب بل ايضا
الى اعناق اكثر سماكه عندما تعمل على جهاز
كمبيوتر او تنظر الى هاتفك يجب ان تنقبض
عضلات الجزء الخلفي من الرقبه لرفع الراس
الاظافر ستتحول لمخالب فالطريقه التي نحمل
بها هواتفنا يمكن ان تسبب اجهادا في بعض
نقاط الاتصال ما يتسبب في تكوين مخلب لليد
الاضرعي ستكون بوضعيه زاويه ال 90 درجه هي
ناتجه عن الوضع المعتاد للذراع عند حمل
الجهاز كذلك جمجمه اكثر سمكا ودماغ اصغر
وجفن اخر فقد يطور البشر جفنا ثانيا اكبر
لمنع التعرض للضوء المفرط ايضا سيكون هناك
جلد شاحب لقضاء سنوات محاصرين تحت وهج
الضوء الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من دبي تنضم الينا الطبيب وعلامه الجينات
ورئيسه مركز الشيخ زايد للابحاث الجنيه
دكتوره مريم مطر دكتوره يسعد صباحك اهلا
بك معنا نورتينا
صباح النور والسرور الغاليه طيب العلماء
يفتكرون نموذج يجسدوا شكل الانسان بعد 800
عام ما رايكم بهذا النموذج
التغيرات او الطفرات اللي صارت على
الانسان مع عمر الانسان يعني اليوم بقياس
الكربون المشع او ذرات الكربون نقدر نعرف
انه كل
375,000 سنه في تحصل تقريبا 500
من الالف ذره يتم تحليلها وعلى الاساس تم
مقارنه من خلال علم الانثرو بايالوجي
تغيرات اللي صارت على شكل الانسان اما
المثال اللي حطيته شويه مبالغ فيه جدا
ومحتاجين فتره اطول في هذا الجانب هل ممكن
شكل الانسان يتغير طبعا ممكن يعني احنا
اليوم كلنا اشكالنا غير عن اشكال الانسان
قبل 300,000 سنه
يعني خليني انا افهم بطريقه علميه فلنفرض
في امراه اليوم همم عملت عمليه تجميل
لانفها مثلا عندها عظمه في انفها هل
معناته بعد اربع اجيال راح يطلع الاجيال
من الاناث والسيدات من هذه من سلاله هذه
المراه منخارهم مثل عمليه التجميل التي
حصلت مش الجين كان عند
لا احنا لازم نعرف ان التغيرات الظاهريه
الخارجيه اللي تجرى بفعل الانسان ما يكون
في تغيير جذري على مستوى دين ايه
التغييرات عاده تحتاج مرور سنوات ويكون في
التاقلم على مستوى الدينيه على سبيل
المثال الغاليه يعني الانسان اللي هو قبل
100 قبل 1,050 مليون الف وخمسين الف سنه
شكلك كان مختلف بسبب حجم الجمجمه وكذلك
حجم الفكين مع مرور الانسان والتاققلم
وانتقاله من افريقيا الى باقي ال- ال-
القرارات اضطر انه شكله يتغير يعني اليوم
انا حنطيه وانت بي وغير
التغيرات صارت تاكل بس مش الجراح
الدراسه اليوم عزت تغير شكل جسم الانسان
الى هذا الحديث
الظهر الى الاستخدام اليومي للساعات
لاجهزه الكمبيوتر والهواتف الذكيه الى اي
مدى هذه يؤثر على النمو الطبيعي الجيني
لجسم الانسان
في نظريه واضحه جدا اللي هي نظريه الطفرات
اللي تصير تغييرات على الجينات بدون ما
يتغير الكائن ان يكون من قرد يصير انسان
او من انسان يصير حيوان هو نفس انسان ولكن
فيه تغييرات افراج دينيه على مستوى الدين
ايه تصير تخليه شكلا تغير نعطيك مثال بسيط
يمكن اوضح للناس اللي يسمعونا في الخليج
والوطن العربي مرض التلاسيميا هذه مرضت
كلاسيميا ما كان موجود ولكن صارت طفرات
على جينتهم اقلبيين عشان يعني يقدر يقاوم
مرض الملاريا اللي كانت في افريقيا
فبالتالي هذه الطفره كانت سبب في نجاه
الانسان اللي كان عايش في افريقيا وانحنا
اليوم استمرينا بوجودنا كمان
ونفس الشيء بالنسبه خاصه للانف نلاحظ اذا
قارن انف اهل الخليج بانف الانسان اللي
موجود في افريقيا هذه التغيرات صارت عشان
الانسان اللي وصل الخليج لازم يتاقلم مع
الظروف الخارجيه اللي موجوده ويقدر يقاوم
الرمال والصحراء وكل هذه التغيرات
شوي فيها مبالغه في الفتره الزمنيه عاده
انت تحتاجين اكثر من
300,000 سنه عشان نوصل الى هذا التغيير
الكبير اللي موجود طيب الدكتوره مريم احنا
لما بنشوف شكل الانسان الاول من حسه هيك
غريب وبختلف عنك بشر وكان انسان
اليوم الاشخاص اللي هيكونوا بعام ثلاثه
الاف هل راح ينظر الينا لمجسماتنا انه
احنا كمان شكلنا غريب زي كيف بنشوف احنا
الانسان الاول اكيد وعدت سبحان الله يعني
الانسان التطور اللي يصير على مستوى
الطفرات تكون للافضل وللاجمل يعني الانسان
اللي بيكون عقب 300 سنه بيكون كثير اجمل
عنا وبيكون حتى في ظروف معينه محتاجين
يتاقلم مع الاشياء يعني اليوم الانسان
يفكر انه يعيش على المريخ وهذا مش حلم هذا
الحلم يكون فيه كثير من ادوات الواقعيه
عشان يتاقلم يعيش على المريخ فيحتاج ان
بشرتك تكون حمراء في تغيرات معينه راح
تصير على مستوى الجينات ولكن ارد واقول
لازم نحط فيه بالنا ان هذه كلها نظريات
وتحتاج وقت الى الاثبات والى التغيرات
اللي تصير في فتره زمنيه محدده ومش فقط في
همم
30 سنه ولا 70 سنه عاده الطفرات تحتاج
فتره اطول وسبحان الله الغاليه يعني
الطفره اذا تغيرت والجيل الجديد ما تالم
الطفره تبدا تضمح هل تطلع طفره جديده عشان
يقدر يتاقلم مع المكان يعني الحديث جدا
ممتعه الحديثه تما ربما في المستقبل شكرا
جزيلا لك من دبي الطبيبه وعالمه الجينات
ورئيسه مركز الشيخ زايد الجنيه الدكتوره
مريم مطر شكرا لك